Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Creating a photorealistic image with fur and
hair is hard.
It is typically done by using light simulation
programs where we use the laws of physics
to simulate the path of millions and millions
of light rays as they bounce off of different
objects in a scene.
This typically takes from minutes to hours
if we're lucky.
However, in the presence of materials like
hair and fur, this problem becomes even more
difficult, because fur fibers have inner scattering
media.
This means that we not only have to bounce
these rays off of the surface of objects,
but also have to simulate how light is transmitted
between these inner layers.
And initially, we start out with a noisy image,
and this noise gets slowly eliminated as we
compute more and more rays for the simulation.
Spp means samples per pixel, which is the
number of rays we compute for each pixel in
our image.
And you can see that with previous techniques,
using 256 samples per pixel leads to a very
noisy image and we need to spend significantly
more time to obtain a clear, converged image.
And this new technique enables us to get the
most out of our samples, and if we render
an image with 256 spp, we get a roughly equivalent
quality to a previous technique using around
six times as many samples.
If we had a film studio and someone walked
up on us and said that we can render the next
Guardians of The Galaxy film six times cheaper,
we'd surely be all over it.
This would save us millions of dollars.
The main selling point is that this work introduces
a multi-scale model for rendering hair and
fur.
This means that it computes near and far-field
scattering separately.
The far-field scattering model contains simplifications,
which means that it's way faster to compute.
This simplification is sufficient if we look
at a model from afar or we look closely at
a hair model that is way thinner than human
hair strands.
The near-field model is more faithful to reality,
but also more expensive to compute.
And the final, most important puzzle piece
is stitching together the two: whenever we
can get away with it, we should use the far-field
model, and compute the expensive near-field
model only when it makes a difference visually.
And one more thing: as these hamsters get
closer or further away from the camera, we
need to make sure that there is no annoying
jump when we're switching models.
And as you can see, the animations are buttery
smooth, and when we look at it, we see beautiful
rendered images, and if we didn't know a bit
about the theory, we would have no idea about
the multi-scale wizardry under the hood.
Excellent work.
The paper also contains a set of decompositions
for different light paths, for instance, here,
you can see a fully rendered image on the
left, and different combinations of light
reflection and transmission events.
For instance, R stands for one light reflection,
TT for two transmission events, and so on.
The S in the superscript denotes light scattering
events.
Adding up all the possible combinations of
these Ts and Rs, we get the photorealistic
image on the left.
That's really cool, loving it!
If you would like to learn more about light
simulations, I am holding a full master-level
course on it at the Technical University of
Vienna.
And the entirety of this course is available
free of charge for everyone.
I got some feedback from you Fellow Scholars
that you watched it and enjoyed it quite a
bit.
Give it a go!
As always, details are available in the video
description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!